[Music]
here in this video we will showcase 10
awesome crap and crustacean monsters
from movies basically creatures with
claws but not arachnids like spiders and
scorpions so without any further ado
please subscribe and if you already have
then let's get on with the monster
content
number 10 queen crap from the 2015 movie
of the same name called queen crab
when a meteor storm crashes down and
destroys a calm lake in the remote
countryside a centuries-old giant killer
crab is awaken this crap is around eight
to nine feet tall or 2.4 to 2.7 meters
and is highly aggressive killing humans
on site
it is pale slash
white greyish in color and appears to be
just like any other crap in appearance
but for the gigantic size
it's a low budget film so the acting is
kind of like a piece of crap but hey we
got a giant monster here so that counts
for something
number nine giant crab from the movie
love and monsters due to a media called
agatha 16 hurtling towards the earth
nations of the world prevented an impact
by destroying it with rockets and
missiles but then this led to a strange
and unique chemical compound raining
down on earth
on its creatures this led to a rapid
mutation among the animal life forms and
one of them is a giant crab that was
created in the same way this creature
was around 10 to 12 feet tall or three
to three point six meters heavily
armored and highly aggressive at first
until the end of the movie where it was
shown that it was in fact harmless
number eight the iraq nuclear from the
most verse movie
godzilla vs kong in terms of general
appearance the arachne claws resemble
giant spiders slash crabs
albeit heavily armored with small faces
and crap like pincers their carapace
resembles rock most likely evolved as a
form of camouflage
they appear to inhabit the open plains
of the subterranean ecosystem of the
hollow earth a camouflaging against the
ground until disturbed by
shockwaves they are likely prey items
for the hollow earth lizards they might
seem small in comparison to the titans
but they are still very big at around 12
to 20 feet tall or 3.6 to 6 meters tall
number 7 the arachne lobster from the
stephen king's movie the miss
as a result of a failed top-secret
government experiment to peer into
another dimension
creatures from that other place came
forth into the world one of them was a
large predator which kills its victims
by cutting them in half in its claws or
biting their heads off the arachnid
lobster is described as a huge
creature having a lobster red
multi-segmented scorpion-like body and
lobster-like claws in the movie the
arachne lobster is roughly 2 story style
meaning around 20 feet or 6 meters with
fleshy not entirely insectile skin
number 6 the opc killer from the star
wars movie a phantom menace
sometimes referred to as simply an op
it was a large carnivorous sea creature
with approximately the length of 20
meters or 65.6 feet in length a hybrid
of a crustacean and a fish it inhabited
the watery planet core of naboo
it was the third largest predator on
naboo smaller than only the colo claw
fish and the even larger sand aqua
monster which brought raid on it so even
though it was 65 feet long its height
however was just around half of that so
just around 30 to 35 feet or 9 to 11
meters tall
number 5 tamatoa from the animated movie
moana he is a villainous giant crab that
covets all things shiny and valuable
in an effort to exude beauty and
superiority tamatoa displays his
collected treasures atop his golden
shell tomato is 50 foot tall
it is a monstrous crab who lives in la
lo tai or also known as the realm of
monsters the concealed crustacean wants
to be more than a bottom feeder and
overcompensates it for this perceived
shot coming by covering himself in all
things shiny he is more than a thousand
years old and can shine bright due to
bioluminescence and he also really hates
the demigod maui
number four ganymedes from the japanese
film the space amoeba
ganymedes began life on sergio island as
a rubble crab of the species daughter
philia jorida otherwise known as the
horrid elbow crab the enemies is the
only one of his space amoeba spawn
brethren to not appear in a godzilla
film afterwards
it primarily fought with its two massive
claws which could snap shut on foes or
be used to clobber it
like clobbering weapons or throw stones
at the opponent this giant monster crap
was 20 meters tall or 65.6 feet
although big and terrible he was still
very vulnerable to human weaponries
number 3 ebirah from the touhou movie
called abra horror of the deep
ebera generally looks like a giant
lobster or a shrimp his body is red all
throughout and has one pincer that is
bigger than the other
he also has two antenna and a giant nose
like shell piece ebra additionally has
multiple legs and multiple segments in
his body leading up to a normal lobster
tail so in short he looks delicious on a
big plate evira was a crustacean that
was mutated to colossal size by nuclear
waste in all of the movies it appeared
it was the same in science which is 50
meters or 164 feet tall
number two oni baba from the kaiju
universe of the pacific rim
although this monster is a kaiju from
another dimension called the antiverse
its body structure and anatomy greatly
resembles that of a crab or a crustacean
this kaiju possesses four large legs
along with two thick claws and two small
arm-like appendages residing in the
kaiju's thorax
onibaba also possesses a high crest
above a large asymmetrical head that can
withstand close range and energy based
attacks
this kaiju was smaller than the rest of
this brethren but was still gigantic at
around 188 feet or 57.3 meters tall
and number one destroyer from godzilla
vs destroyer definitely the most
powerful enemy
uh
the ultimate foe that godzilla has ever
faced this demonic creature was a result
of a multitude of smaller organisms
clumping in together
originating as a colony of microbes that
mutated as a result of exposure and
incorporation of microoxygen into them
from the previous death of the original
godzilla that was destroyed by the
oxygen destroyer weapon
this creature transformed several times
as the movie progresses from small tiny
microbes to his ultimate form which was
a 120 meters or four feet tall
demonic-looking kaiju
his powers are many which includes dna
absorption a chest beam deadly claws
thick skin and an even deadlier tail and
a killer look so this monster is the
biggest crustacean monster on this list
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash that bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
you